a porter cabin in a lorry park in kent
is the unglamorous heart of last minute
preparations for brexit
government contractors here explain new
customs procedures that will apply in
just 35 days
with or without a deal but it's not
straightforward
you ready for january the first no angry
okay where are we from come from sir
slovakia
french
kingdom here catastrophe the majority
of drivers are from eastern europe and
many don't speak english
so google translate and patience is
required
there's another issue the crucial piece
of software
drivers will need to cross the border
isn't ready
and it won't be available until around
december the 23rd
that's just eight days before brexit and
hawley's
are worried this is the shambles the
government tells us
what we have to do but not how to do it
and that's to do with the gvms the it
system
that will make all this work it's been
shared with only a very small number of
operators who know how it works or if it
works
and most of us don't know and that's an
absolute crisis
with 30 days to go instead of traveling
freely within the eu
from next month drivers will have to
make multiple customs declarations
freight forwarder john shirley has been
brokering trade through dover for 25
years
he says the volume of paperwork and the
potential for delay
could overwhelm the border petrified
terrified we we don't use work like this
we are pretty hard bit we lurch from
from crisis to crisis and we you know we
we just don't know what to think about
we share
in fact the view that the haulers have
taken is that the sensible thing is not
to come here at all
there was a taste of what may lie ahead
this week when a french customs trial at
the channel tunnel
caused five mile tailbacks on the m20
boris johnson says you can't put a price
on sovereignty
but there's little question brexit will
make us poorer
official forecasts say that even with a
deal brexit will knock
four percent off gdp no deal
knocks off another two percent and of
that almost
half is due to border delay so what
happens
down there really matters to the
national bottom line
brexit is about to become a test of
competence rather than conviction
the government's challenge to safely
navigate its chosen path
paul kelso sky news in dover